using all I've learned I'm cooking a
dish that does justice to my culinary
adventures I know nobody's going to help
you right I'm really on my own and to
make matters worse seamless bringing
some influential food critics seen some
absolutely fantastic stuff a week from
the desert to the jungle to even on the
train so time to put that into practice
and basically as it is in Ramsey's world
the knives are out first I'm going to
get my chickens off the bone take off
the legs take off the breasts get them
into a marinade at the same time get
your chicken stock going the dish shop
staking my reputation on is slow cooked
chicken with cinnamon cardamom and
cloves I'm a really nice sort of brown
fragrant stock aromatic not like any
normal chicken stock you find in the UK
in with that cinnamon this delicate
chicken stock will be the base of my
sauce so
very [ __ ] water how do you get out no
wonder there's no talking water Louis
pissing out down the bottom Jesus that's
not normal well if there's one thing I'm
learning the hard way
it's don't cook an important dish like
this in a poorly equipped kitchen or no
one speaks English cling film cling film
no Kevin Eatonville no no okay don't
worry a sick now I'm not like this but
like a
now burn my [ __ ] onions star anis
aniseed star star star star star star in
the skies
star anise seed fennel star step now I
know [ __ ] wave at me [ __ ] me star
anis I need know if I succeed tonight
you'll be a miracle at this rate
I'm in this [ __ ] now yeah everyone
stands and stares and [ __ ] last I'm
in the [ __ ] now and i marinate the
chicken now in the green for fire this
marinade is adapted from the one I used
for the GoPro yani at the wedding
chilli will touch a clove outer cumin a
little bit of turmeric a little bit of
salt and a little bit of sugar get that
mixed in you know I'm on the fly Joe
it's a collection of what we've seen
where we've been a week and more
importantly you know if it doesn't work
I'm gonna look [ __ ] stupid so it has
to work all right chicken the breasts in
so I go
I found a pumpkin to make a puree
there's no conventional oven to bake it
in here so time to use the one golden
rule of indian cookery think on your
feet
improvise like we did in the jungle i
want to borrow your pend orielle phone
yeah thank you
[ __ ] that's hot